je pense que c'est vrai je voulais qu'un
opportuniste parce que c'est logique
donc tu vois quand je vois une bonne
porte qui s'ouvre devant moi et appui à
la base c'est des bonnes des bonnes
opportunités des vraies bonnes
opportunités j'en ai pas eus beaucoup
dans ma vie tu vois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
je
[Musique]
ou des fausses dents mais chez moi des
fois dedans mais pas seulement pendant
un mois des fausses dents mais dehors
des fausses dents mais dans un local des
fausses dents mais dans un hôtel des
fois j'étais dans le sud et fois jetés
dans l'est et dans l'ouest
voilà c'est pas gabon d je me suis
construit un peu comme ça tu vois
[Musique]
quinze saisons je crois j'ai des
problèmes ici avec la police tout ça est
pas si je retourne là bas je sais que là
c'est une ville que j'ai fréquentés donc
je retourne là bas il ya deux trois mecs
qui sont pas fait virer qui sont
toujours là braqués je connais donc on
se voit un petit peu évasif je tombe sur
une copine je m'installe avec elle
j'avais je crois 16 ans 17 ans n'est pas
qc le 16 ans à l'époque il avait 22 23
ans je me sens qu'elle a vécu des choses
tellement six mois jusqu'à que je me
fasse attraper jeu mais choisir là bas
moi dans mon cas ça m'a forgé vu que
j'ai pas une éducation diamant vraiment
tu vois proprement dit pas rentrer à la
maison n'hésitez pas chez moi et j'ai
pas eu d'éducation aussi national de
l'éducation
tu vois de l'école et où il a fallu que
je me forge par ça donc là heureusement
que j'ai pris de la maturité que j'ai
grandi vite
[Musique]
quand les jeunes surtout car la peur de
l'adolescente dirait qu on a un problème
avec ça avec la morale et ou comment
t'expliquer même tes parents quand tu
donnes des conseils tu as l'impression
que c'est parce que tu es un mot mais
tout est dit souvent tu comprendra plus
tard tu vois aujourd'hui je sais que le
conseil s'était vraiment ce qui permet
de se forger pas de se faire manger ici
là tu vois quand tu es jeune tu veux pas
trop comprendre mais le fait que ce soit
un juge est qui et qui montre vraiment
qu'il a envie que je m'en sors dans la
vie je pense que ça pour n'importe quel
jeune c'est un facteur de confiance
c'est bien
[Musique]
je me suis accroché c'est la première
fois que travailler vraiment parce que
je pensais aussi comment travailler même
si c'est devenu une passion mais c'est
un travail aussi
donc je me suis accroché avec ces
facteurs là il fallait patienter puis
entre danger et j'avais jamais mon
premier et mon fils tu vois donc il ya
plein de choses comme ça tu vois si la
prison tous ces trucs là je voulais plus
je vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
en vérité sur internet tout ça veut dire
même le public tout ça y est envahie 6
25% de ce que je vis vraiment de ce que
je dors du risque j'ai ce que j'éprouve
[Musique]
un regard perçant de fou et mon jeu mais
un petit billet sous directement voilà
le pari pas la retrouve dans une
épicerie dans une hutte deux minutes
après s'est fait voler son argent
je la vois en train d'essayer mieux
parler et pleure hama voilà ma décharge
je me rappelle me sont fermées dans la
voiture une demi heure je les paie pour
ça je me dis [__] c'est un truc de fou
quand même et le fait qu'elle soit jeune
qu'elle se regarde personne qui ont
marqué et de me dire qu'ils soient
pauvres qu'eux mêmes se fait voler ça va
faire mal au coeur je vois le guide est
parti il est descendu dans les
bidonvilles la trouvais bien le demeurer
marne et je lui ai discuté un peu avec
elle et tous et trois jours après je
retourne l avoir su retourner chez elles
tout ça tu vois jamais sa famille
donc elle n'a pas de maman s'est fait
tuer devant elle car elle avait 9 ans et
j'ai tissé des liens avec elle
[Musique]